he is one of my favorites and I'm not
just saying that because he's sitting
there waiting on hold he personally
eyeballed the astros calling game one of
the ALDS on MLB Network between the Sox
and the Astros alongside Jim Cobb he is
Bob Costas here on the show how are you
Bob hey rich how you doing I'm doing
well look you know I am a die-hard
Yankee fan and I don't mind admitting it
do you root for any specific team do you
when was the last time you rooted for a
team as a fan Bob well when I was
growing up I rooted avidly for the
Yankees and for the Giants of ye tittle
and Frank Gifford and company when I
first became a baseball fan the Giants
and Dodgers had left New York late
fifties early sixties the Mets didn't
even exist yet and the Yankees were the
power in baseball so it was natural that
I became a Yankee fan once I moved to
st. Louis after college and started
doing games on a national basis it just
didn't do any good to root you root for
good storylines you know that you look
at the team that's behind to catch up
and at least make it interesting if it's
200 in the series you don't really care
how it turns out you just want it to go
the full 5 or the full 7 or whatever it
may be if you're doing a football game
you want it to go down to the last
possession so that's what you kind of
root for on national broadcast no I sure
I understand that but you know your good
friend ours Al Michaels I mean he's he's
got season tickets the Los Angeles Kings
practically I think he wants to be out
there skating when the cup gets awarded
quite frankly Bob I mean do you do you
go to any hockey games like that as a
fan any any sport just I go to games I
go to games the fan I don't have an
intense rooting interest except in st.
Louis for the Cardinals because my kids
grew up in st. Louis as Cardinal fans
and when the Cardinals were in the World
Series in 2011 when they wanted a
miraculous fashion or in 2013 when they
lost to the Red Sox on those kinds of
postseason runs a Bartman st. Louis and
I'm at a Cardinal game of course I'm a
Cardinal fan I'm surrounded by friends
and fellow st. Louisans we're rooting
for the Cardinal so yeah that would be
my one attachment but it doesn't get in
the way if I'm not on the card became on
national TV it doesn't get in the way
No
I you know I wouldn't I just was
wondering about you is just a fan just
you know punching the ticket going and
grabbing a beer or grabbing a popcorn or
something just sitting there just like
you know cuz owl owl is nuts about is la
king he's no doubt about that
in terms of the excuse that we had heard
from Dusty Baker where does a pitcher
that might have been scratched due to
mold rank for you Bob in the annals well
there have been people who threw their
backs out pulling on their cowboy boots
and it seems to be to me that an
inordinate number of athletes have
kitchen accidents you know before the
Super Bowl or before the World Series
you shouldn't really be whipping up an
omelet or carving a turkey but it seems
that there's an inordinate number of
household and domestic mishaps that
occur to athletes often on the eve of
very important game and then and then he
he looked like Jordan with the flu I
mean he was he was something else Bob
what do you think about a game 5 that's
tonight in the nation's capital here
well as last night proved in Cleveland
one baseball game is so different not
only from one football game where there
is only one each round of the playoffs
but even a single NBA game or a single
NHL game if you have a hot goalie I
guess maybe you can say one team over
the other it makes solid sense but if
you've got two teams good enough to make
it to the postseason and you're playing
in one game other than the small edge of
being in your home ballpark and padding
lasts there isn't all that much to
choose from almost anything can happen
in a single baseball game and that was
proven when the Yankees came back from
o2 and beat the team that might by
season's end have been the best team in
all of baseball they came in hottest
they had the best second half they were
the best team in all of baseball the
Indians were and then the Yankees blew
game two and they went up to nothing and
they were as good as declared dead and
they not only come back and win three
straight
they beat the like lee siyoung Award
winner Corey Kluber on his home field in
Game five
go figure so anything can happen in a
single game and then we should see who
the Dodgers play I guess when it's all
said and done obviously when Game five
is done in terms of you know what we
have seen from the Dodgers what do you
think makes them so good Bob what do you
think well the guy at the top of the
rotation Kershaw even though his
postseason history doesn't match his
regular-season history his regular
season history truly makes him one of
the greatest pitchers in the history of
baseball
not just the Hall of Famer one of the
greatest pitchers in the history of
baseball but his postseason history
doesn't match that maybe he can begin to
turn that around this October look you
got the guy at the top and then you got
the guy at the back Kenley Jansen is one
of the two or three best closers in all
of baseball and their lineup has become
more and more formidable you know you
add a young Seeger and Bellinger to the
mix and Justin Turner who was just a guy
when he was with the Mets and other
places now this guy is a tremendous
force in the middle of their lineup they
can score runs in bunches or they can
score them in a variety of ways and it
seems to me that Dave Roberts is a nice
steady hand at the helm when they were
winning 43 of 60 he wasn't over the moon
when they were somehow losing 16 or 17
he wasn't on a Ledge somewhere this
could be the year that they break
through for the first time since 88 and
then you personally eyeballed the Astros
what do you think makes them so good Bob
well again you're talking about young
core Altuve is only 27 and yet he's been
in their organization since they signed
him out of Venezuela at age 17 correo
was the first draft pick at the Jeff
lune out took over the organization Alex
Bregman was also an early first-round
pick which Springer was an early pick so
there's four young players usually the
first four hitters and their lineup and
then they were smart enough to sprinkle
in some veteran presence not just
because of what they can contribute on
the field but because of what they can
mean in the clubhouse
Carlos Beltran's of the Josh Redax
the Brian McCann's and then the final
piece that they really needed
Justin Verlander just in the nick of
time as the clock was ticking towards
midnight August 31st turning to
September 1st they get Justin Verlander
they played six games that he started
since then and they've won them all and
Bob Costas here on the Rich Eisen show a
couple more minutes with Bob I brought
this up with Gammons and and for doochie
I should bring it up with you to an
interview I had with the Jerry Seinfeld
a couple weeks ago he talked about one
of the things he loved about baseball is
what he said the democracy of talent and
physique in this sport and then you've
got this ALCS with a six foot eight Erin
judge and a five foot five Jose Altuve
going against each other for the right
to play for the World Series do you
recall a bigger disparity between two
MVP candidates in a situation how this
ever that that is an interesting thought
now I happen to be someone who takes a
keen interest in this particular aspect
of sports so I know all your Albie
Pearson's and your David X times I know
you're bobby fences I know that whitey
Ford was only five nine or five ten by
route somewhere in the back of my mind I
root for players like this or Jose
Altuve is the guy who's carrying the
banner now but you put it in an
interesting place
Altuve I must say and his behalf is
listed at five seven I don't know he's
actually five five but he is listed at
five seven okay at 165 and Aaron judge
is listed as six seven and 282 you know
that is about as big a gulf as you could
ever imagine because they aren't just
two players they are like you say likely
to be the two players who in some order
or other finish one two in the MVP
voting but it is the beauty of this
sport isn't it Bob right I mean you
scored like it in that rig it is and in
fact when I was calling Game one in
Houston a week ago I said the Jim kaat
here in the booth
you got five six and six five okay
look look down on the field Dustin
Pedroia's only five nine and he was the
MVP in what 2008 and Altuve is only five
seven and he might be the MVP this year
and Mookie Betts is only five nine and
he was second to Mike Trout in the MVP
the year before and so what Seinfeld
said is correct but democracy of size in
baseball and even players who are over
six feet tall you look at Carl Edwards
of the Cubs a slender slinger
it looks like he's pocketing his meal
money and not paying me I'm not not
using any of it he's just eating it the
minibar at the hotel or something you
know on on the other hand you could be
the same height as Carl Edwards but
weigh 300 pounds like Suzy's are happy
so if you're the measuring stick are you
taller than Jose Altuve Bob do you look
down on him when you interview him when
you chat you know I it's an eye to eye
thing we've never truly stood
back-to-back but if we do I'm gonna
demand that he takes off the spikes
first you have the penny I mean let's
you know it's got to be a fair a fair
situation right right know what I I
think the way to go is you just remove
your shoes and you know you go in your
stockings me before I'm afraid of is and
I don't want to find this out and I
always used to say because I'm an honest
man you'd go to the doctor for the
yearly physical and it was always like
five six and five eighths so you round
that off and I always said five seven
sure as you get older you might lose a
fraction of an inch I think honesty may
cause me to rounded down to five six but
five six and six five sounded funnier
than five seven and six five that's why
I said it that way with God hey you're
all about the good TV Bob I mean that's
why it's why I have all the Emmys before
I let you go before I let you go what do
you think would be the most entertaining
World Series matchup based on the teams
that are still alive as we check you you
do not have a team still alive that
doesn't have a great story compelling
players interesting managers it's all
good the biggest TV thing would be
Yankees Dodgers no question about that
but you can't sell the Nationals the
Cubs or the
astro short about dodging the question
sir but they they all have really
interesting stories and how the teams
were built in who their stars are AJ
Hinch is not a national figure but he's
a forty three old manager who really
knows what he's doing and I think if he
ever got to the could the biggest
national stage of the World Series he'd
come across very well and people would
take a liking to him who doesn't like
Dusty Baker Joe Maddon in his own way
has been quirky and successful and
really interesting in both Tampa and in
Chicago the Yankees are the Yankees and
it's been a long time for the Dodgers
and here would be the irony how about at
the Dodgers win the World Series the
first year that Vin Scully is not
broadcast there's something wrong with
that isn't it yeah I agree with you Bob
it's amazing man meet Stan Musial
retired in 1963 and the Cardinals won
the World Series in 1964 and they hadn't
wanted since 1946 when Musial was a kid
that's just not right well I feel the
same way about Mattingly he leaves in 95
and then the Yankees going on that Torre
run for the ages as soon as you retired
perfect example Bob great chat as always
take care I read see you soon take care
you bet that's the one and only Bob
Thomson the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about